today we're talking about vm migration
custom voice and disaster recovery i'm
jen and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
google cloud vmware engine helps
simplify your migration to google cloud
the service provides a dedicated
software defined data center that allows
you to continue to use the core vmware
applications you need to run your
business in the cloud without changes to
your tools processes or policies
in a recent survey by idc they found
that 78 of businesses realize payback in
one year or less after they migrate
learn how to maximize your returns on
the blog
we are excited to announce the general
availability of custom voice in our
cloud text-to-speech api
a new feature that lets you train custom
voice models with your own audio
recordings to create customized
experiences
for businesses looking to build a strong
brand identity this is a game changer
for customer experiences
check out the blog for supported
languages and more detail
there are many reasons why locality
restrictions need to be taken into
consideration and it's something chief
information security officers and
resiliency officers need to factor in
a balance needs to be met between taking
advantage of your best features of the
cloud while meeting your locality
requirements
google cloud helps you meet your
business's objectives whether your
architecture is all in on google cloud a
hybrid pattern which may be on premises
and google cloud or on google cloud in
an alternative cloud provider
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud